Greg Jennings former Green Bay Packers
Super Bowl champion Green Bay Packer fox
sports analysts good to see you here
seventh round 2020 that's that's
basically like we're done here right
like bye you can you can have them what
does that mean for the running game you
think they're no it doesn't change
anything for the running game why I
don't like don't get me wrong I was at
AI Montgomery fan I think he what he
provided for them was that hybrid where
he posed a matchup problem if you were
able to get him out on a linebacker he's
a great route 1 over C is exactly and
but that's my point here Greg let's
because this game let's get into hey
let's do it because why would the fact
that time Montgomery was a running back
means a few things one is that the
Packers always had problems keeping
running backs healthy that's nobody's
fault
it always happened that's why he wore
number 88 he's kept the number whenever
they had to they were out of options
they had to turn to him was that two
three years ago when he ran out of
options and running back for Aaron
Rodgers but then they kept him there
instead of just like that's a stopgap
for one year and it just seems to me why
not get this guy a guy who can go 2025
carries 100 yards I know Aaron Rodgers
is terrific but we just saw Sony Michele
what that offense for New England looked
like well he was healthy for Tom Brady
what is there just some philosophy in
Green Bay that doesn't make that happen
I think when you are dealing with an
Aaron Rodgers a guy who is young now
he's he's starting to turn that corner
or approaching the corner coaching the
corner yep you put so much on him in his
shoulders because he's been able to do
it you feel like we can kind of survive
without it we don't really need it but
understand this the best friend of a
quarterback obviously the left tackle
but a running back yeah take the
pressure off when you don't have to make
that throw every single time you drop
back that is the life Aaron Rodgers has
had
to lead and live his entire career in
Green Bay does he like it though deep
down do you think do you think he won't
he would rather have he had his brothers
he would rather have somebody behind him
I think he's getting to the point where
he he wants a running back he would
rather have it early on yeah he wanted
that like put the ball in my hands every
single snap every single play I can make
it happen and I think everybody got
mesmerized by that and kind of lulled to
sleep by the success that he was able to
provide them to where you almost took
that position for granted and now he
goes down you're off France is abysmal
because you don't even have a running
game you never had you never established
one because everything we did was based
off of Aaron Rodgers even running the
ball his ability to to extend the plays
and get outside the pocket and make eyes
miss and it keep the change moving
because of his legs well he was
everything he is everything he is I know
yeah I know it so you're not you Aaron
Jones is not gonna be a god that they're
gonna turn around and try and hand it to
1520 times I mean he does seem to me
equipped to physically be able to handle
something I definitely would I love his
explosion his explosiveness his speed
his burst it's like a it's almost like a
bolt of energy when he gets the ball in
his hands it's you would think and they
have gotten better they have definitely
gotten better with running the ball and
not bearing the shoulder of the burden
of winning every single game from first
quarter to fourth on Aaron Rodgers by
establishing a running game and I think
when you have a guy like Aaron Jones and
even Williams but Aaron Jones
specifically he's a game changer but you
have to give him the ball I know how
give him how I would love to see that I
would love to see that I'd love to see
Aaron Rodgers not have to every single
damn game trying throw these back
shoulder passes along the sidelines
because he has no timeouts left to try
and get but he's tremendous at it it's
incredibly entertaining for a fantasy it
is that's why it was particularly
galling to see ty Montgomery take the
ball out because I mean
I would have thought a 999 times out of
a thousand that's gonna lead to a Mason
Crosby attempt you know obviously we saw
him to join last this year that it's not
a guarantee but I would just think that
to keep more tread on them Rodgers tired
just get somebody to run the football
for yes and in going to the time
Montgomery decision like for me as a and
I thought it was not the right decision
to bring it out
selfish whatever whatever has been going
on whatever had been said about it I
don't think it was the right decision
but I understand a player and being
frustrated and not getting opportunities
and having the ball approach you and now
it's in your hand I want to make a play
I mean we've seen it with Odell Beckham
this year going on as a punt returner
because he his frustration of not
getting the ball from Eli look I just
want to get on the field get the ball in
my hand and try to make something happen
that's what players do that's what
competitors do but it ripped every it
was almost like it robbed us as fans as
viewers as as team as teammates players
the opportunity to see what could have
possibly been regardless if he takes him
down there in a score Greg Jennings in
the Honda inside a report here on the
Rich Eisen show but I guess when
something is wrong in a locker room when
something's off in the locker room when
a guy does not just sit there ago I
understand I'm not getting my
opportunities but I'm trusting in the
process trusting in the team trusting in
my teammates because they trusted me
that's when moments like this happen
when that those moment when something
toxic takes over a locker room
I'm not saying something toxic is
pervading the entire locker room but
there does seem to be something going on
between the quarterback and the coach
that they are not on the same page Aaron
Rodgers is way too smart to not be
passively aggressive like he is being at
the podium okay he's some tweeting
without tweeting Mike McCarthy in this
offense I think of that there is no
doubt what he
think you obviously are conversant in
the language or Theran rocks
so this is always interesting for me
because when I talk about the Green Bay
Packers I mean all the Packer fans I
love them but they are they are uber
sensitive when it when you talk anything
about McCarthy or the but it's truth I
have I have attacked his play calling
years ago and it's is it's been
problematic it's been an issue in house
even when I was there like we we would
grow frustrated because it was I mean he
would say things like you know we can
play doubleheaders and yeah you could
but we're one in the same place there's
no what do you innovation so that's the
problem there's no in your running the
same
yeah it's there's no creativity there's
no Andy Reid like effect and I get it
Andy Reid is special you know but when
you have playmakers and Rogers alluded
to this you have a guy like Davante
Adams obviously he can get off the press
but sometimes make it even easier for
your guy bring them in motion create
plays that are suited for for him that
will just ignite your offense a lot
simpler it simplifies easier for them to
get open so that now you're putting the
pressure and the stress on the defense
to guess what are you gonna do but when
you just line up the same way all the
time and granted they have the luxury to
do this because every guy on that
receiving core and on that roster base
they can mix and match them everybody
knows every position so you're not just
gonna have a guy running the same thing
but it makes it easier win or a more
exciting for even you as a player when
you're going into the game plan and
you're going into a game and the game
plan is like man I got some
opportunities this week that doesn't
exist in Green Bay no that that's not
I've never seen because it's it's one of
those places where you want to make sure
everybody gets an opportunity and make
sure everyone's when we were when I was
there and we had five
we add myself Donald Driver Jordy Nelson
James Jones Randall Cobb that's five
guys I can get it done that's true
we never although I got a lot of the
attention I never had outlier seasons
where it was just my numbers were just
ridiculous no why because the premise
was we gotta make sure everybody gets an
opportunities and that that's not a good
thing it is a good thing when you have
the talent to do it but when you don't
have it you don't have the talent to do
it get it to your guy what's wrong with
that everybody else in the NFL in this
league does it it's okay so you're
saying the offense is so simple to
figure out because that they're because
they've been running the same plays
right so going into béla checks house is
that what is that well I wouldn't go as
far as saying that offense is so simple
it's it's just not as complex as you
would think it could be with a guy like
Aaron Rodgers running your office so why
hasn't it changed all these years I mean
Aaron Rodgers obviously has some
influence he had a contract that needed
to be rescind you got a guy like Mark
Murphy in the front office who knows
football at the top of the chain here
and let me let me let me share this with
you
when does the Green Bay Packer offense
look the best when it's two minutes to
go and it's in the air do you think our
who do you think has full control over
that offense then number 12 number 12
he's calling us when when that is the
case there or he he takes it to a
completely different level because he's
now calling the plays he's dictating
every it's it's like a point guard with
the ball in his hand and look we have no
more timeouts oh I can't I can't look
over I can't come over to coach we can't
get the play I got to run what I know
I'm gonna run and what I feel like it's
gonna work that's what he does so I
can't back yard footballs and then why
can't he gets control over the other 48
minutes that's not happy I mean or the
other 58 minutes that's not had why I
mean that's not no Peyton Manning did
you know for all those years hmm
Mike that's not what Mike is doing Mike
is not going
with dealing with Brett it goes back to
Brett when you dealt with a guy who you
felt like he was
I call him somebody in that but he was
like what a what the wild child okay
where you couldn't control what Brett
did
plus it was Brett Favre coming exactly
we were be in the huddle in it would be
like the play would be called we here in
the helmet of bread and he's like what
can't hear we're not running that okay
that was Brett it might lived it and it
was like the moment that transition made
that baton was handed off Aaron had no
leash you are I am NOT going through
this like what I experienced with Brett
with you and that's he's not gonna give
that up that's what's called an insider
report right here so why doesn't Aaron
do that is Aaron doing it why didn't you
pull it far from that respect and and
any in a way though I did this does
whole conversation make it seem
MacArthur doesn't know what he's doing I
mean he has to know what he's know we
had these conversations and if we make
it seem like McCarthy's not a great
coach he is a great coach he's a really
good coach and he knows what he's doing
and he but he wants guys to do it his
way and I get every coach once that but
adds some and he he does defer he does
allow errand to run the two-minute
offense it just so happened we look a
lot better when he's recalling the plays
Wow
so how did you think this plays out what
do you think happens here because it
just seems to me you know three three
and ones not cutting it when they're all
said and done and something's got to
give here right I mean either Aaron
Rodgers gonna finish his Packers career
with a coach who he clearly is not on
the same page with or would would
management let that happen you know I
think when it were can they coexist I
did they've coexisted for this long for
this long and you know we've always
given a my opinion Green Bay it passes
where
Aaron Rodgers doesn't have the talent he
doesn't they don't have the personnel
around him they don't look man when you
look who they're playing Sunday night
that's never bit that has never been an
excuse or a reason for them not to be
successful personnel they find a way to
make it work they sure do
they overcome what they do not have and
that's one thing that the Green Bay
Packers have not been able to do with
one of the in my opinion the best
quarterback in the game the most
talented Tom Brady's the most decorated
go give them that most talented
quarterback in the game you have not
been able to overcome what you do not
have and that's where the frustration
grows and Fester's so will McCarthy be
there I think so because I think it's it
goes beyond just wins and losses for the
Green Bay Packers it's relationships
it's have we had success when a coach
has one yeah it was nine years ago but
they are a viable team every single year
if 12 stays healthy last question for
you on this subject by the way up can
you stay one more second can you do it
good time yeah like it's right sir okay
if not thought so it's all good
last question I know it's an unfair
question but that's the way I'm going to
preface it and Greg Jennings but it's
question everybody's gonna be talking
about this week I'm already seeing a
whole bunch of conversation about him
Aaron Rodgers says Bill Belichick is his
head coach how many Super Bowl rings is
yet man I think he has just as many if
not more than Tom Brady absolutely
there's no disrespect it's all Brady I
mean we we tom is even saying it he
would throw this first 7,000 yards like
we the talent level it's not about the
talent that Aaron possesses is a level
that most quarterbacks are looking and
salivating at Patrick that's why that's
what makes Patrick mahomes so I'm so
enticing because we see that
favre Aaron Rodgers skill set in talent
and he's able to produce the smarts the
drive the understanding of it's not
about me the unselfishness that just
that just makes them look even more
appealing Greg Jennings here on the
Honda inside a report where both of us
removed from the Mike McCarthy Christmas
card list here on the return I mean
because that's the subtext this whole
conversation really is I didn't fire him
though no I know no he's still there and
stay there and by the way if the in the
Packers part ways he will get a job oh
no questions flat no question he's he's
a really good coach the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience